Donald Trump did not stay home over the
weekend and he gave what I can remember
as the most deflated low energy speech
of his political career Donald Trump
actually gave two speeches over the
weekend he went to Georgia and spoke to
the Republican convention there and then
he flew to North Carolina and spoke to
the Republican convention there I have
never seen Trump like this before
completely deflated
um
I'm just going to play some clips for
you these are only from his North
Carolina speech
um that the Georgia speech was less
remarkable in in a sense so we will just
give you a sense of what was discussed
and even the crowd like not really big
other than when Trump said
anti-transgender stuff which we will get
to here is Donald Trump just sort of
ranting about how we went to UPenn and
saying look they indicted me they
indicted me they're thinking I was a
very good student at the Wharton School
of Finance can you imagine I wonder if
they're proud of me I got indicted I
wonder if they're saying oh that's
wonderful I've been indicted twice now
in a couple of months you know when I
was studying and when I was uh very very
successful businessman then I did The
Apprentice and I did lots of books that
were big big big big sellers yeah even
now I have books that are tremendous
sellers I never had
I never had this stuff in mind I never
had the word indictment
what's indictment mean sure that's when
you're extremely dishonest sir
so as you can see
blabbering and blathering aimlessly and
it only got worse Trump talking about
Ron DeSantis criticizing him and I guess
the crowd sort of like this I don't know
if I weren't leading
we wouldn't be talking about it but
we're leading by a lot we're leading to
sanctimonious by Massive numbers he's
he's heading south quickly no
personality you gotta have a personality
to win he's got no personality
yeah and you know remember I mean even
Trump's heart doesn't really seem in
this ridiculous speech and I'll tell you
if I was under the indictments that
Trump is under
I wouldn't be able to go out there and
give nice speeches and be upbeat I like
I actually get it I actually get it but
this is important in order to understand
that the things Trump's saying about oh
this is going nowhere and there's
nothing here this is very serious stuff
uh and Donald Trump knows it on some
level Trump's saying that now it's
actually hard to say DeSantis because
he's gotten so used to using the
nicknames for DeSantis G6 that means
we're leading Ronda sanctimonious by
56 69 percent for Trump 13 for Des
Sanctus
and pentastics you know once you get
used to saying to scientists it's hard
to say to Santos I was actually being
interviewed I was trying to be serious
and I called them to Sanctus I said
that's not good but he's changing his
name you know now it's D santis
and I put a little message out never
change your name in the middle of a
campaign
I have to admit that actually is funny
it seems one of the stupidest things you
can do if you're trying to get name
recognition is pronounce your name two
different ways DeSantis and D Santas
Trump trump actually in the midst of all
the legal chaos able to put together a
little kernel of good political advice
Donald Trump then seemingly unable to
stop talking about massive dumps I know
guys it's it's hard to believe he's at
it again with the dumps
but we can stop them called and we will
and we would have had him stop cold and
they know that and they cheated like
dogs they cheated like nobody's ever
cheated like a dog or you turn on your
television at 10 o'clock you would have
said Pennsylvania is a lock
we were up by so much I like all of a
sudden you see that big fat dump that
big dump at 302 or whatever it was in
the morning it's a disgrace what
happened
uh beautifully put right I mean truly a
Wordsmith uh
it's it's beyond parody Trump then
talking about how there is a taint in
New England it's a it's a taint such a
big big business such a powerful
business and such an important business
New England as a liberal tint but we're
taint I would say taint is a better word
right but it it's a little bit on the
liberal side they say
such a big big business such a powerful
business and such an important business
uh okay Trump talking about the CNN Town
Hall
and this was building to the highest
energy moment of the night which of
course was an anti-trans moment like
it's almost like you're not gonna get
the crowd riled up about tax policy
you're not going to get the the crowd
riled up about getting people health
care or dealing with the environment
you're going to get people riled up with
anti-tran stuff but in the midst of that
Trump commenting on the CNN Town Hall
New England
sorry what this is the wrong clip here's
the correct clip did you see the town
hall with CNN
they got one of the highest ratings
they've had in like 11 years and they
end up firing the guy because it was
Trump
and said they should celebrate we had
our highest ratings you're supposed to
get paid for high ratings Richard
but then one of the highest ratings
they've had in many many years I was on
with a young woman who was I said nasty
she was a very nasty woman but it worked
out very well and they were all going he
owns you
screaming AOC you're screaming he owns
you get him off the air stop it stop it
but you think if they had high ratings
that would be a big he should ask for an
increase instead they fired him because
I was allowed to put across our point of
view it's hour there you go and now you
can see a guy using his smartphone to
film Trump's entire speech just it's all
so depressing here's the highest energy
moment and this won't surprise you
Trump's highest energy moment was when
he talked about anti-tran stuff and he
even acknowledges wow people really like
hearing this nonsense in critical race
Theory transgender insanity
and other inappropriate racial sexual or
political content of our children
Standing Ovation there
[Applause]
it's amazing how strongly people feel
about that you see I'm talking about
cutting taxes people go like that
talking about talk about transgender
everyone goes crazy that is incredible I
would have thought five years ago you
didn't know what the hell it was
that is an unbelievable statement Trump
is really summarizing in that statement
the absurdity of his own movement they
don't care about actual policy they care
about trans culture War anti-woke
nonsense this is a revelation
about what is animating the right today
Trump says I talk about taxes people
barely clap I talk about the trans stuff
and people go absolutely crazy this is
the monster they built and the question
now is whether this is a monster that
can get them a president in the Oval
Office I hope and to some degree believe
that the answer is no
all of these clips will be available on
all of our various platforms YouTube
Facebook Instagram Tick Tock Etc make
sure you're following us wherever you
like to consume your video content we're
going to take a quick break and then
continue our coverage of this completely
absurd farcical weekend in American
politics
here is the perfect Father's Day gift
get him a Wi-Fi connected digital
picture frame from Aura our sponsor Aura
has been named the number one best
digital picture frame by wire cutter the
strategist and wired this is not one of
these early 2000s picture frames there's
no USB or SD cards and you get free
unlimited storage and you can instantly
frame photos and videos from any device
anywhere in the world I have several of
these I got my dad one and so now I take
pictures of the baby load them into his
or a frame and they show up and
everybody loves it you know it's no more
of these having to bring a slideshow
When I visit I just put the pictures
right in the frame I'm really glad I got
him one of these and right now Aura has
a great deal for Father's Day go to
auraframes.com Pacman use the code
Pacman to get thirty dollars off plus
free shipping this deal ends June 18th
so don't wait terms and conditions apply
the link is down below